[Musik]
guten Abend liebe Zuschauer kurz nach
halb elf ein bisschen später als gewohnt
ist ist gut dass sie wieder mit dabei
sind die Menschen in der Ukraine sollen
frieren auch das ist ein Teil von Putins
Strategie aus Städten ohne Strom und
Heizung sollen sie in diesem Winter
fliehen auch zu uns von einem
historischen fluchtwinter ist deshalb
die Rede dabei sind schon eine Million
Ukraine hier und es kommen ja auch
Menschen aus anderen Teilen der Welt
schafft Deutschland das noch einmal wie
schwer wird es in Zeiten steigender
Preise und wachsende Verunsicherung das
fragen wir uns und diese Gäste
bundesinnenministerin nennt sie Feser
SPD
Carsten Linnemann Vize-Vorsitzender der
CDU
Migrationsforscher Gerald Knaus
ca Yildiz Geschäftsführerin der Tafel
Deutschland
spiegeljournalistin Ann-Kathrin Müller
und Boris Palma Oberbürgermeister von
Tübingen
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner und
die begrüßt die Gäste dieser Sendung
nochmal ausgesprochen herzlich und schon
geht's los eine Million
Ukrainer sind geflohen aus ihrem Land
hier zu uns nach Deutschland und
vielleicht werden es noch mehr
über eine Million geflüchtete aus der
Ukraine alles ganz anders als 2015 wir
haben jetzt etwa in Niedersachsen
100.000 etwas mehr als 100.000 Menschen
aus der Ukraine die aufgenommen worden
sind und das führt in der Summe dazu
dass wir heute mehr Menschen in
Niedersachsen haben als 2015
ja aber diesmal mit anhaltender
Solidarität
viel Zuspruch für Frauen und Kinder
und wieder den alten Problemen wir sind
überall in der Kapazitätsgrenze
angekommen und damit sind auch hier die
letzten Betten belegt die Wohnung
Situationen war ja vorher schon
angespannt und jetzt kommen neue Leute
kommen mehr Leute noch nach Deggendorf
in den Landkreis gibst du selber Geld
kriegst den Zuschuss von oben wir können
diesen Eigenanteil nicht mal leisten
schon greifen die alten Reflexe Schuld
an der Misere nicht ukrainische
Asylbewerber
Schattenboxen in Bayern es muss sich die
Bundesregierung darum kümmern und nicht
so tun als ob sie noch beliebig viele
zusätzliche weitere Flüchtlinge
aufnehmen könnte eine Differenzierung
die im Qualm vor Ort längst verglüht
großströtendorf in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern erst das
Hakenkreuz dann der Brand Ursache
ungeklärt alle 14 ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge können sich retten
in Bautzen der nächste Brandanschlag auf
ein geplantes Flüchtlingsheim
das hinterlässt mächtig Eindruck im
thüringischen Eichsfeld storniert der
Landrat diese dringend benötigte
Unterkunft
wir haben die Halle nicht in Betrieb
genommen weil wir die Befürchtung hatten
es eskaliert uns wie war das noch der
Schwur durch alle Parteien
die Fehler des Jahres 2015 dürfen sich
nicht wiederholen das darf sich nicht
wiederholen dass das nicht auf Dauer
sich jedes Jahr wiederholen kann es darf
sich nicht wiederholen
ja wir müssen ein bisschen ordnen Nancy
fazer ist bei uns die
bundesinnenministerin Frau Feser die
Vereinten Nationen sagen 14 Millionen
Flüchtlinge hat putinskrieg für die Welt
für Europa schon bedeutet mit wie viel
mehr Flüchtlingen rechnen sie eigentlich
in diesem kommenden Winter der ja noch
vor uns steht also wir haben erstmal
seit dem 24 Februar seit dem furchtbaren
Angriffskrieg Putins in der Ukraine
immer gesagt wir können nicht genau
voraussagen wie viele Menschen die dort
ja sehr schlimm von Bomben und Angriffen
fliehen müssen tatsächlich das Land
verlassen wir haben sehr viele binnen
geflüchtete die in der Ukraine geblieben
sind und die meisten sind ja in die
Nachbarländer geflohen Polen die
Slowakei wenn sie
können wir nicht habe ich nie gemacht
halte ich auch für unseriös jetzt im
Moment sind die Kämpfe wieder ganz ganz
stark worunter den Menschen sehr leiden
es wird ihnen Strom abgedreht wie sie
gesagt haben also es wird ja sehr massiv
auf die Menschen dort eingewirkt gerade
dass es natürlich eine sehr schlimme
Situation was dazu führen kann dass mehr
Menschen sich auf den Weg machen wir
fragen jemanden der uns bei der
Beantwortung dieser Frage vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr helfen kann wie wohl das
extrem schwer ist zu schätzen Gerald
Knaus ist bei uns Soziologe
Migrationsforscher Herr Knaus sie
sprechen von einem historischen
fluchtwinter bezieht sich das
ausschließlich auf die Flüchtlinge die
aus der Ukraine kommen also darauf die
Antwort ganz klar ja wir haben zwar auch
andere Asylsuchende aber sowohl in der
Europäischen Union als auch in
Deutschland sind bis jetzt in diesem
Jahr zehn von elf aufgenommenen aus der
Ukraine und in diesem Winter wird sich
das noch mehr zu in Richtung
Ukrainerinnen verschieben aus
verschiedenen Gründen bin ich überzeugt
die irreguläre Migration aus
Südosteuropa die sogenannte Balkanroute
wird zurückgehen aus vielen Gründen kann
man diskutieren das wissen auch die
meisten Innenministerien auch in
Österreich etwa wo es viele Asylanträge
gibt spricht man von der Entleerung
genau aber für die Ukraine der
Entleerung der Balkanroute also viele
die vor zwei Jahren in Griechenland
waren am Festland auf den Inseln die
sind jetzt nicht mehr dort weil in
Griechenland Menschen sehr schlecht
behandelt werden und die kommen
anerkannte Asyl anerkannte Flüchtlinge
40.000 oder mehr in Deutschland und
andere aber es kommen nur noch sehr sehr
wenige aus der Türkei nach Griechenland
also es gibt derzeit in diesem Jahr
keine große irreguläre Migration aus
Afrika oder aus aus der Türkei in die
Europäische Union oder aus Afghanistan
oder aus Syrien es kommen kaum Leute in
die EU nach also wir haben eine
Verschiebung in der EU und die wird an
einer natürliches Ende kommen und das
ist nicht der Fall bei den Ukrainerinnen
die sind ja vor allem Frauen und Kinder
die kommen legal da gibt es eine einzige
fluchtursache das ist der Krieg von
Putin und Putins ziel ist es die
Europäer mit der Angst über Flüchtlinge
in die Knie zu zwingen die Gesellschaft
zu spalten
er hat gesehen wie nervös europäische
Regierungen reagiert haben auf die
kleinen Zahlen aus Belarus und er
erwartet dass der Europäer wenn jetzt
noch einmal in diesem Winter eine
Million zwei Millionen kämen das war ja
die Zahl die in wenigen Wochen im
letzten Winter im Februar März gekommen
sind wenn er die Infrastruktur zerstört
wenn er die Städte bombardiert mit
iranischen Drohnen das ist eine
Größenordnung mit der sie auch rechneten
mit der auch Deutschland rechnen muss
wenn Deutschland rechnete mit dieser
Größenordnung im letzten April da haben
wir viele gesagt man bereitet sich vor
wenn Szenario von zwei Millionen der
Grund warum es nicht dazu kam wiederum
ein einziger eine einzige Erklärung die
Ukrainer haben im Krieg am Schlachtfeld
das Glück gedreht Kiew wurde entlastet
der Bürgermeister konnte ab April sagen
ihr könnt zurückkommen und ab Mitte
April sind jeden Tag mehr Ukrainerinnen
über Polen in die Ukraine gegangen als
aus der Ukraine empfohlen gekommen jeden
Tag Millionen ist das Gegenteil der Fall
es ist eine terrorstrategie von
Wladimir Putin
zu nicht nur zu beobachten sondern sie
findet einfach statt und sie vertreibt
Menschen natürlich aus den Städten und
wir rechnen hier mit einer steigenden
Zahl von ukrainischen Flüchtlingen
weiter Boris Palmer ist uns aus Tübingen
heute zugeschaltet frisch gewählter
Oberbürgermeister der Stadt Herr Palmer
am Ende sind das andere Flüchtlinge
heute aber die Mathematik gewinnt und
auch diese Flüchtlinge wollen und müssen
untergebracht werden und brauchen eine
Wohnung und brauchen einen Platz zum
Verbleiben und müssen versorgt werden
das stimmt deswegen kenne ich auch
keinen Kollegen der bezweifeln würde
dass wir alle die aus der Ukraine zu uns
kommen aufnehmen müssen wegen Proteins
Angriffskrieg es geht um die Frage wie
wir das tun und da wir in einer Welt
begrenzter Ressourcen Leben entstehen
ressourcenkonkurrenzen zum Beispiel um
Wohnraum um guitaplätze um
grundschulplätze wenn wir das so tun wie
wir es derzeit tun dass wir die Menschen
gewissermaßen so aufnehmen als würden
wir sie voll integrieren und das müssen
wir diskutieren ob das richtig ist ob
das richtig ist im Hinblick auf die
Ukraine die sich eigentlich nicht
leisten kann dauerhaft diese Menschen
alle zu verlieren in Europa in
Westeuropa und ob es richtig ist im
Hinblick auf die Konkurrenzen die dann
bei uns entstehen und die Probleme die
wir in den Kommunen dann nicht mehr alle
auffangen können sie müssen das noch mal
erklären Sie es gibt ja ein besonderes
Verfahren die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge
betreffend die müssen nicht mehr dazu
gab eine Richtlinie des Europarates sie
müssen nicht mehr durch das
Asylverfahren sondern sie sind im Grunde
anerkannte Asylbewerber ach quatsch
anerkannte Flüchtlinge Entschuldigung
und mit diesem Status müssen sie
logischerweise nicht mehr durch das
Verfahren selbst und bekommen damit
Hartz IV
und das ist das Problem dass sie nicht
so das Verfahren müssen halte ich für
völlig richtig wie gesagt es gibt
niemand der bestreitet dass wir diese
Menschen aufnehmen müssen ob sie
deswegen sofort wie Inländer behandelt
werden sollten also Hartz IV erhalten
das sogenannte rechtskreiswechsel ist
umstritten der baden-württembergische
Städtetag und der Landkreistag sagt wir
halten das Verfalls und wir würden es
für richtig halten sie wie Asylbewerber
also mit den niedrigen Leistungen des
Asylbewerberleistungsgesetzes zu
behandeln es geht aber nicht nur um
diese sogenannten rechtskreiswechsel
sondern es geht wie gesagt jetzt
mittlerweile weil die Reserven
aufgebraucht sind um die Frage welche
Art von Unterkunft bieten wir ist es der
Anspruch eine Wohnung zu stellen oder
gehen wir in massenunterkünfte und
bieten wir auch alle weiteren
Integrationsleistungen auch dann
konkretes Beispiel in Tübingen ist
mittlerweile die Zahl der fehlenden
Kitaplätze etwa so groß wie die Kinder
von geflüchteten und da entsteht
natürlich dann Druck und darüber müssen
wir sprechen ob es nicht vielleicht
besser wäre eine Art kriegsnothilfe zu
leisten als die Idee der Integration von
Anfang an zu betreiben Ann-Kathrin
Müller ist bei uns aus dem
hauptstadtbüro des Spiegels geschätzte
Kollegin Frau Müller wir haben zitiert
und nicht ohne Grund zitiert dass alle
Politiker diesen Satz 2015 darf sich
nicht wiederholen sprechen sie helfen
uns dabei zu sagen was anders ist als
2015 und warum es so ist dass
offensichtlich viele etwas anderes
verstehen wenn Sie den Satz sagen
wiederholt sich 20 15 nicht weil wir in
einer ganz anderen Lage sind man hat
direkt entschieden dass diese
Flüchtlinge sofort ein Aufenthaltsrecht
haben das heißt die Behörden sind nicht
irgendwie überfordert überlaufen oder
sonst irgendwas am Anfang 2015 hatte man
die Strukturen halt noch nicht die hat
man dann gelernt also damals gab es
tatsächlich Situationen dass hier am
LAGeSo irgendwie Wäschekörbe standen wo
Reisepässe gesammelt wurden und dann
musste man nachher nicht mehr zu wem
gehört und Menschen standen da genau das
gibt es alles nicht mehr es gibt auch
nicht das Problem dass die Kommunen
nicht grundsätzlich wissen wie sie das
Aufziehen müssten man hat leider meines
Erachtens diese Strukturen sehr
zurückgebaut obwohl man eigentlich
wissen konnte dass natürlich weiter
Flüchtlinge kommen und weiß ja
Klimakrise und so weiter das ist kein
Problem was irgendwie weg ist selbst
wenn man einen Deal mit Erdogan macht
oder ähnliches das heißt die Kommunen
sind besser aufgestellt die Behörden
sind besser aufgestellt jeder weiß was
er tut man setzt immer noch sehr aufs
Ehrenamt muss man sich überlegen ob man
das will weil irgendwann können Ehrenamt
auch wegbrechen
aber dass diese Rhetorik jetzt wieder
Einzug erhält das finde ich das wirklich
erschreckend der Regel weil dann hat man
nichts aus 20 15 gelernt wenn man jetzt
wieder anfängt diese Debatten zu führen
wer darf hier wie hin und zu welchen
Sätzen und wie soll man die integrieren
und so weiter dann hat man leider nichts
aus 2015 gelernt was da weil das hat nur
Rechtsaußen geschadet geholfen das ist
jetzt das Stichwort für Carsten
Linnemann stellvertretender
Parteivorsitzender der CDU wenn jemand
ausgerechnet in einer Situation wo die
Menschen in diesem Land wachsend Angst
und Sorge hatten und wo so eine
wachsende Zahl von ukrainischen
Flüchtlingen gibt Haut der Vorsitzende
mal einen aus und spricht von
sozialtourismus hat sich dafür
anschließend entschuldigt ist das nur
ungeschickt gewesen oder ist es auch
gefährlich wie Frau Müller sagt ja das
doch glaube ich an gleicher Stelle Frau
ellener hier gemacht insofern ist das
jetzt verschüttete Milch es ist passiert
und entscheidend ist und darüber reden
wir auch in der grundsatzkommission der
CDU das ist auf der einen Seite
Humanität geht und auf der anderen Seite
Rechtsstaatlichkeit zum Thema
Rechtsstaatlichkeit kommen wir ja gleich
noch dass wir mit Flüchtlingen die zum
Beispiel illegal hier sind dass sie hier
nicht rein dürfen in dieses Land dass
sie auch an der Grenze zurückgewiesen
werden auf der anderen Seite Humanität
wie jetzt
im Bezug auf die Ukraine das muss
gewährleistet sein das kann nur
gewährleistet sein denn wir uns selbst
nicht überfordern gerade der Taxifahrer
hier der mich ins brachte der sagt in
Berlin fängt man jetzt an auf Hotels
zuzugehen wo Flüchtlinge bzw die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge dann
unterkommen ich habe heute noch mit
einem deutschen Landkreistag gesprochen
es gibt den Baden-Württemberg
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern in Bayern in
Sachsen ganz viele Länder die sagen wir
können nicht mehr zwölf von 16 Länder
können nicht mehr aufnehmen ich spreche
fast jeden Tag über das Thema Bildung
wir haben bei der Integration Probleme
es sind immer mehr Menschen in der
Schule die kein Deutsch sprechen ich
will nur sagen es ist alles gut und
richtig aber ich unterstütze auch ein
Palma in dem wir uns nicht überfordern
dürfen und darum geht es vor Inna und es
ist glaube ich ein wichtiger wichtiger
Aspekt das ist natürlich der wichtigste
Aspekt weil eigentlich will man ja in
der Sache reden aber noch mal die Frage
ist so etwas wir hören noch mal ganz
kurz rein von der Nacht wir leben
mittlerweile einen sozialtourismus
dieser Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland
zurück in die Ukraine nach Deutschland
zurück in die Ukraine da haben wir ein
Problem das wird größer
das waren Kollegen auch aus der Union
verstört und haben gesagt das hat mit
unserem Wertekompass nichts zu tun in
unserer Partei und es ist ja
offensichtlich auch eine Behauptung die
gar nicht stimmte
Friedrich Merz hat dazu alles gesagt ich
kann dazu nur sagen man muss den
Hauptsitz hier haben in Deutschland
natürlich kann man auch mal zurück in
die Ukraine das ist alles rechtens nur
am Ende des Tages
ja genau deswegen können sie ja auch
wenn sie mal zurück wollen alles
rechtens ich kann nur sagen Frau ellner
entscheidend ist die Frage dass wir
nicht im halben Jahr wieder sitzen und
sagen jetzt ist dieses Land überfordert
ich erlebe es in manchen Orten dass
jetzt Turnhallen genommen werden wo die
Vereine sagen es kann auch nicht sein
ihr habt monatelang es gewusst die
Erfahrung auch aus 2015 und jetzt fangt
ihr an Mehrzweckhallen zu blockieren wo
wir als Vereine reingehen irgendwann
kippt ganz kurz Frau Müller ganz kurz es
kippt irgendwann die
Integrationsbereitschaft deswegen ist es
gut dass wir jetzt in dieser Sendung
darüber reden weil wir seit Monaten
diese Zahlen haben es gibt ja es ist ja
überhaupt noch kein Vertrauensverlust
von irgendwas die Rede man sieht das
auch an Umfragen nicht und so weiter und
es ist wirklich schwierig gleichzeitig
anfangen und nicht warten bis später
man darf aber auch nichts herbeiräten
und ehrlicherweise ist ein bisschen
einfach zu sagen das war kein normaler
Vorgang da hat er märz nicht aus
Versehen mal was gesagt die ganzen ja
darüber reden was man aber vor vier
Wochen ist oder sollen wir mal über die
Sache reden wo das herkam diese Info und
die kam aus russisch pro russischen
querdenkerkanälen und Co das war
russische Desinformationen die der Chef
der größten Oppositionspartei in
Deutschland gesagt hat und dann hat er
sich nicht entschuldigt mit oder bin ich
auf was reingefallen sondern wenn das
jemand verletzt hat dann tut es mir leid
das ist keine richtige Entschuldigung
meines Erachtens und wir müssen schon
aufpassen dass wir wenn wir Probleme
identifizieren
differenziert und konstruktiv darüber
reden wir können nicht wieder den Leuten
sagen es kann alles ganz schlimm werden
sondern müssen sagen was können wir
leisten und was können wir machen und
wie können wir es machen Frau Feser die
Vorwürfe von der Saskia esken der
Parteivorsitzende der SPD die waren
immens sie gab Friedrich März eine
Mitschuld für Hass und Hetze in diesem
Land die dann auch in Gewalt münden kann
sehen Sie das auch so also heilen sie
diese harte Kritik von Saskia meine
Auffassung nach ist es zumindest nicht
gut so etwas herbeizureden also es gab
keinerlei Grundlage für das was Herr
Merz gesagt hat und meines Erachtens ist
in der Bevölkerung eine riesen
Solidarität da und man soll auch nicht
herbeiräten was an Stimmungslage gar
nicht da ist und insofern verschlimmert
das eine Situation insofern kann das
Stimmung auch anheizen deswegen war es
so falsch was Friedrich Merz dort gesagt
hat und es entbehrt jeder Grundlage es
muss es noch mal sagen es war
tatsächlich so dass in den sozialen
Medien das Pro russisch gesteuert war
dass wir in Deutschland so viel zahlen
würden dass alle geflüchteten aus den
Nachbarländern hierher kommen das stimmt
einfach nicht in Polen hatte man
beispielsweise direkt den Zugang zu
Sozialhilfe was ist in Deutschland gar
nicht gab und es war trotzdem nicht so
dass alle nur in Polen geblieben sind
sondern auch welche weitergegangen sind
wo sie auch Verwandtschaftsverhältnisse
haben ich habe ganz ganz viele
Ukrainerinnen
kennengelernt persönlich auch mit ihnen
gesprochen was ich nur vermeiden will
ist dass wir jetzt eine Situation herbei
reden die es in Deutschland gar nicht
gibt was ich sehr gefährlich finde
beispielsweise wenn wir nach Bautzen
gucken was die AFD gemacht hat sie hat
eine Stimmung herbei geredet die zu
Gewalt an einer Flüchtlingsunterkunft
geführt hat und auch Menschen hätte
treffen können
Sie zwei Tage vorher in einer Art und
Weise
demonstriert haben und Sachen
behauptet haben die einfach nicht
stimmen dann Hass und Hetze gegen
geflüchtete und die Konsequenz war dass
zwei Tage später eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft in Bautzen
gebrannt hat und deswegen können solche
Äußerungen auch solche Taten bewirken
und deswegen sollten wir uns alle
miteinander
doch darauf
konzentrieren was in der Bevölkerung die
Stimmung ist und ich bin niemand der was
schön reden möchte also ich bin ganz
auch bei den Kommunen ich habe vor
kurzem mehr die kommunalen
Spitzenverbände eingeladen vielen
BürgermeisterInnen Bürgermeister geredet
und ich habe sehr viel Verständnis wenn
die sagen wir haben Kapazitätsprobleme
wir müssen da gemeinsam Lösungen finden
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch noch mal
eingeladen um Geld es geht auch um
Jobcenter da klopfen jetzt 600.000
zusätzliche Kunden an die ja auch
funktioniert überraschend gut also wenn
man sich auch das mal anguckt alle haben
befürchtet das wird ganz schrecklich das
wird nicht bewältigt es wird bewältigt
es klappt gut bei den Base und wenn ich
das noch gerade sagen darf was ich
wichtig finde ist dass wir in so einer
Situation eben eher helfen und den
Kommunen zur Seite stehen deswegen habe
ich eingeladen dass wir gemeinsam
darüber reden Bund Land und Kommunen wie
wir noch zusätzliche Unterkünfte zur
Verfügung stellen können es gibt immer
noch bundesligaschaften die zur
Verfügung gestellt werden können und die
Länder waren auch bereit in dem letzten
Treffen vier Plätze in die 4000 Plätze
annotiert glaube ich das ist so viel wie
man sich tausend schon zur Verfügung
gestellt jetzt und es wir haben 6.500
weitere Liegenschaften die man dann auch
noch zur Verfügung stellen könnte
insofern ist da viel drin und auch die
Länder haben sich bereit erklärt dazu
unterstützen und das ist aus meiner
Sicht der richtige auch ein Weg wir sind
bei Boris Palmer und sagen nochmal und
erinnern uns Herr Palma daran dass Sie
Friedrich Merz damals in der Sache recht
gegeben haben damals klingt so als wäre
es irgendwie in 21 gewesen wir reden von
vor einem Monat haben Sie denn das sie
haben es im Grunde schon gesagt sie
sagen wir können wir sollten den
Ukrainern im Grunde nicht diesen höheren
standardzahlen sondern sie wie
Asylbewerber behandeln
also den Begriff sozialtourismus halte
ich für völlig daneben und dafür wird
Friedrich Merz zurechtkreditiert aber
unser Landrat hier in Tübingen der auch
stellvertretender Präsident des
Deutschen Landkreistages ist sagt ganz
klar wenn man in die Pässe schaut leider
wird es nicht systematisch gemacht aber
wenn man in die Pässe schaut dann sieht
man den jüngerer Zeit dass da viele
kommen ukrainische Staatsbürger die
vorher Zuflucht bereits in
südeuropäischen Ländern gefunden haben
und es wird aus Gesprächen auch deutlich
dass dabei das äußerst hohe
Leistungsniveau in Deutschland eine
Rolle spielt das wäre überraschend wenn
es nicht so wäre und daraus resultiert
schon die Forderung diesen zusätzlichen
Effekt da wir an unseren
Kapazitätsgrenzen Arbeiten einer
sekundärmigration in Europa nicht noch
zu befördern durch diesen sogenannten
rechtskreisswechsel und es bei den
früheren Leistungen zu belassen ich kann
auch gar nicht verstehen warum man
ukrainischer Staatsbürger
andere Leistungen erhalten muss als ein
tierischer kriegsflüchtlings sind ja
beides Kriegsflüchtlinge
europäische Richtlinie die das genau
vor Knaus und dennoch ist dieses Jahr
jetzt erstmal eine ganz logische Frage
also es gibt zwei ganz logische Fragen
diese Flüchtlinge gehen ja in der Regel
relativ schnell wieder nach Hause zurück
und wollen das auch warum sollte man sie
denn eigentlich voll integrieren in eine
Gesellschaft und das ist ja das Argument
von Herrn Palma gewesen wenn wir
eigentlich uns für Sie wünschen dass sie
möglichst schnell wieder in ihre
Familien zurück können und in ihrer
ja also zunächst ist das muss man schon
präzise sein es gibt nicht zwei Arten
von Flüchtlingen es gibt Asylsuchende
und anerkannte Flüchtlinge die Ukraine
wurden eben ohne Asylverfahren anerkannt
jetzt ist die zweite Frage und das ist
eine Frage die muss jedes Land
entscheiden welche Leistungen gibt man
ihnen und da kommen wir auf eine sehr
interessante Frage es ist wahr die
meisten Ukrainer dreimal so viele pro
Kopf sind in Tschechien in Warschau
allein nur in der Stadt Warschau sind
140.000 Ukrainerinnen mit Kindern mehr
als in ganz Baden-Württemberg die
Tschechische Republik hat dreimal mehr
pro Kopf als Baden-Württemberg mit der
gleichen Einwohnerzahl die schaffen es
so jetzt ist aber die Frage heißt das
dass die Kommunen nicht recht haben wenn
sie sich beklagen dass sie überfordert
sind weil die Verwaltungen und das ist
mein Eindruck aus vielen Gesprächen mit
ausländerämtern mit mit Sozialämtern die
fühlen einen enormen Druck weil sie sehr
sehr viel mehr Fälle zu bearbeiten haben
weil sie Krankenstand haben weil sie
Leerstellen haben weil schwer fällt
Leute zu rekrutieren ich glaube wenn man
da ansetzt und Verfahren vereinfacht
wenn man da sagt okay wir stehen vor der
größten flüchtlingskatastrophe seit den
40er Jahren in Europa wir stehen vor
einem Versuch durch Terror gegen
Zivilisten Europa zu erpressen wir
müssen so signalisieren an Putin dass er
damit keinen Erfolg hat da müssen wir
das Land zusammenhalten und konkrete
praktische Lösungen finden weil nochmal
ganz konkret gefragt würden denn weniger
ukrainische Flüchtlinge in dieses Land
kommen wenn sie 150 Euro weniger
bekämpfen also die meisten Ukrainer in
Polen Tschechien wie in Deutschland sind
von Familien aufgenommen und eine der
spannenden Fragen ist kann man und das
ist entscheidend weil wenn die
Zivilgesellschaft jetzt nicht mehr
mitmacht wenn die das wenn die
überfordert wird dann dann wird das
Problem unlösbar in Polen in Tschechien
wie in Deutschland kann man den Familien
mehr helfen und jetzt hat dieser
rechtskreiswechsel ist ja möglich das
gibt auch Wohngeld
ich glaube aber das Problem ist es ist
sehr kompliziert man bräuchte ein System
wo man es ermöglicht dass eine Familie
wie in England sagt ein Haushalt wir
nehmen für sechs Monate jemanden auf das
ist da einen unkomplizierten Zuschuss
gibt da gibt es Möglichkeiten das
auszuzahlen dann muss man der Familie
kein Wohngeld mehr bezahlen das ist für
den Staat billiger und diese Person käme
unter für sechs Monate da muss ich aber
dazu sagen was die Integration betrifft
was ist denn Integration Kindergarten
und Schule für Kinder die ohne ihn schon
traumatisiert sind dass man und man weiß
nicht wann sie in das kaputte mariopold
oder Kaki wieder zurück können ich habe
das erlebt in Bosnien das sind ja auch
einige zurückgegangen aber wie lange hat
es gedauert die Gebiete sind und von
Russen besetzt die Infrastruktur wird
zerstört da gibt es keinen Strom da gibt
es keine keine so das heißt denen jetzt
ein möglichst normales Leben zu bieten
ist sinnvoll aber ich bin total bei
Herrn Palma wenn man da die Frage stellt
wie könnte man die Deutschland entlasten
kann man beispielsweise eine umsetzbare
Lösung auf europäischer Ebene hätte und
ein Vorschlag warum ist es nicht möglich
für Haushalte in Toulouse in Bordeaux in
Valencia in Lissabon sich auf einer
europäischen Plattform zu melden zu
sagen wir wollen helfen aus einem
europäischen Fonds diesen Haushalten
500 Euro zu geben und dann können
rechtliches möglich dann können die
Ukrainerinnen die jetzt vielleicht in
den nächsten Monaten in Moldau oder
Warschau ankommen auch dort hingehen und
nicht in der Natur inhalle in
Baden-Württemberg denn in ganz
Frankreich haben derzeit nur 20.000
Ukrainerinnen bei Familien Unterschlupf
gefunden frankreich hat insgesamt
weniger aufgenommen als nur
Baden-Württemberg und ich glaube wenn
wir die Debatte in Lösung in die
Richtung von Lösungen lenken haben wir
jetzt aber gleich einen guten Impuls in
genau diese Richtung zu denken wir
fragen als erstes würde ich sagen Boris
Palmer ist das etwas also erstens haben
wir eine völlig neue Situation man muss
in Europa darüber nachdenken wie man die
Polen die Tschechen und Deutschland
entlastet und könnte Vorschlag von Herrn
Knaus einer sein der die Unterstützung
des Oberbürgermeisters von Tübingen
findet wo sie sagen das ist ein guter
Ansatz wieder lieber mehr zurück die
private Aufnahme der ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge zu fordern und zu fördern
und auch finanziell zu fördern als eben
nun nach Containern nach Turnhallen nach
hotelsschutz zu schauen lange Frage hier
ist die Antwort ich finde ich finde es
ein sehr guten Vorschlag zumal wir im
Moment eher erleben dass die private
Aufnahme aus dem Frühjahr an den Ende
kommt und die Leute sagen das geht jetzt
zu lang wir können nicht mehr und die
Stadt soll dafür wieder die
Verantwortung übernehmen auch eine
europäische Denkweise gefällt mir sehr
gut ich glaube da Nikon Benedikt hat vor
fünf sechs Jahren schon mal was ganz
ähnliches vorgeschlagen ist leider nie
realisiert worden und im Hinblick auf
Lösungen würde ich auch gerne das Thema
Kindern noch mal ganz praktisch
ansprechen weil mich das sehr umtreibt
wir haben wirklich ein dramatischen
Mangel wenn Erzieherinnen nicht da sind
dann kann unter Umständen die Ärztin
arbeiten weil das Kind nicht versorgt
ist und es gibt es Land auf Land ab man
könnte auch sagen Gebäude zu finden ist
einfacher machen wir Spielgruppen für
die ukrainischen Kinder wo ukrainische
Eltern die Betreuung übernehmen lassen
wir die ganzen deutschen Standards des
kommunalverbands für Jugend und Soziales
weg weil dann ist das alles von
vornherein verboten sondern lassen wir
die Kinder dort zusammen doch auch von
ukrainischen Eltern betreuen und geben
dazu noch ein bisschen Geld für
Spielmaterial das würde entlasten und
würde diese Konkurrenz die ich fürchte
mit den Eltern die sagen ich kann nicht
mehr zur Arbeit gehen weil ich kein
Kitaplatz Kriege deutlichen schärfen ist
ja toll dass wir dieses Mal kein
stimmungsproblem haben das nehme ich
auch so war umso mehr sollten wir uns
konzentrieren auf reale Lösungen die
diesen Druck rausnehmen aus den
überlasteten Systemen Herr Knaus hebt
gerade nochmal den Finger Herr Müller
ist dann dran nur zwei Fakten genauso
haben sie das in Tschechien gemacht
ukrainische Freunde von mir sind in Prag
angekommen und da gab es eine
selbstorganisierte Gruppe die hatte
einen Raum und da war sofort ein Platz
für die Kinder in einem den Kindergarten
nach einer Woche ich glaube da muss man
einfach pragmatischer denken und das
zweite in England hat es so ein Programm
da gibt es ein Programm Haushalte können
sich melden für sechs Monate sie kriegen
einen sie kriegen einen Zuschuss ich
jeden Monat 350 Pfund die Erfahrung bis
jetzt ist 70 Prozent sind nach den sechs
Monaten bereit weiterzumachen 30 Prozent
nicht ich glaube auch in Deutschland ist
es klar wenn jemand sein Wochenendhaus
eine oder eine Zweitwohnung oder Räume
zur Verfügung stellt und jetzt steigen
die Energiepreise jetzt steigt die
Inflation und man hat keine
Unterstützung dann ist es schwierig aber
ich glaube und manche können auch nicht
länger aber wenn man der
Zivilgesellschaft in Deutschland und in
Europa sagt es geht hier wirklich um
eine humanitäre Großstadt wir werden
erpresst diese Frauen und Kinder wollen
zurück sie können aber jetzt nicht
emporäres genau
ist endlich dran dann Herr Lindemann ja
das ist so ein bisschen die Frage
natürlich ich bin auch für pragmatische
Lösungen die Frage ist halt können wir
wirklich annehmen dass diese Frauen und
Kinder schnell zurück bekommen also der
Winter kommt ist kommt Eis man weiß
nicht wie der Krieg sich entwickelt wir
tun ehrlicherweise als Deutschland nicht
so viel wie andere Länder dafür um der
Ukraine zu helfen in diesem Krieg mit
Waffen und Co das heißt
wenn man sagt man möchte dass diese
Leute zurückgehen können weil sonst
schaffen wir das nicht dann muss man auf
der anderen Seite das andere tun man
könnte aber auch sagen wir haben ein
wahnsinniges Problem in Deutschland
Arbeitskräfte zu finden und Menschen die
hier grundsätzlich bleiben wollen oder
bleiben müssen sollten wir soweit
integrieren dass sie eben dann auch auf
den Arbeitsmarkt 85 Milliarden Fehlen
jedes Jahr geht der deutschen Wirtschaft
verloren weil es nicht genug
Arbeitskräfte gibt und noch ein Punkt
die Frage der pull-faktoren das sehe ich
so nicht also das was Herr Palma sagt
dass Leute hinkommen weil sie irgendwie
150 Euro mehr bekommen oder so das ist
durch nichts belegt außer dass es
erstmal auf den ersten Blick logisch
klingt aber die Leute ziehen dann
vielleicht noch mal um weil sie
Familienmitglieder woanders haben oder
sonst was es gab in anderen europäischen
man sehr viel früher Zugang zum
Sozialsystem und die Leute sind aber
trotzdem hier hingekommen also das ist
so einfach nicht sonst würden die Leute
auch nicht in Polen Tschechien und Co
bleiben wir haben den Mann wir können
noch mal eine andere Frage stellen und
können sagen die Menschen werden nach
anderthalb zwei Jahren hoffentlich
wieder in ihre Heimat zurückgehen sie
gehen ja sogar jetzt während des Krieges
schon wieder zurück weil sie eben in der
Ukraine sein möchten und in ihren
Familien leben möchten und helfen wollen
wäre es nicht völlig in Ordnung Ihnen
für diese Zeit dieses höhere Geld
zugestehen warum ist es so ein Problem
also erstmal glaube ich auch dass der
Großteil ganz klar zurückgeht und
schnell zurückgehen will bei allen
anderen Flüchtlingen das haben wir 2015
bis heute gesehen die wollen ganz klar
nach Deutschland weil wir die höchsten
den den höchsten sozialstandard weltweit
haben da gibt es gar nichts dran
drumherum zu reden
man merkt das jetzt auch im Moment die
Polizei die Bundespolizei im Moment
fängt jeden Tag zwischen 450 und 500
Personen auf die unerlaubt einreisen wir
haben im Moment beim BAMF beim Bund beim
Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge
1200 bis 1500 Erstanträge das ist schon
ein Problem 20.000 im Oktober
Frau Feser sie kennen die Zahlen 160
170.000 das muss man einfach realisieren
und das darf man auch nicht kleinreden
das sind Menschen die wollen gezielt
nach Deutschland die wollen nicht nach
Bulgarien die wollen gezielt nach
Deutschland erster Punkt zweiter Punkt
natürlich müssen wir aufpassen bei den
pull-faktoren und ich ich teile das was
was Herr Palma sagt wir müssen schon
einen Standard haben für diejenigen die
hier Zuflucht suchen und die Idee privat
zu unterstützen von der Knaus finde ich
klasse warum weil wir die ersten
Indikatoren haben wo viele sagen ich
würde gerne jemanden aufnehmen aber ich
kann mir die Heizkosten nicht mehr
leisten für dieses Zimmer das dann jetzt
der Staat sagt kommen wir unterstützende
klasse Idee nämlich gerne mit und
versuche ich mit umzusetzen
unbedingt also ich würde gerne auch noch
mal anfangen weil das mit den
pulfaktoren ist wirklich durch nichts
belegt ist stimmt einfach nicht dass
Menschen hierher kommen weil sie mehr
Geld bekommen das ist durch nichts
belegt das muss man einfach noch mal
festhalten und ich möchte noch mal den
Ursprung zurückgeben wir haben ja was
historisches geschafft als Europäische
Union wir haben im Februar bzw ein paar
Tage danach als der Krieg ausgebrochen
ist als Putin diesen furchtbaren Angriff
gestartet hat haben wir ja diese
Richtlinien in Gang gesetzt die ja
Kriterien hat also auch zum Beispiel den
Zugang zum Arbeitsmarkt der ist darin
geregelt weil jetzt auch die Frage ist
wie kann man Übergänge organisieren also
wir haben eine Rechtslage die vorsieht
dass wenn man so eine richtliniengang
setzt wegen eines Kriegsausbruchs dass
wir eine sehr schnelle Integration damit
auch verbinden ich wollte das nur noch
mal sagen weil das hier so ein bisschen
in der Diskussion jetzt war ist es
können wir davon abrücken oder nicht es
ist erstmal die Rechtslage und ich halte
das auch für richtiger Knaus hat das
gesagt die Kinder sind schwer
traumatisiert die hierher kommen die
brauchen eine Struktur die ist eine
Kindertagesstätte eine Schule wo sie
normales Leben bekommen auch mit anderen
Kindern und möglichst auch mit Kindern
die sich hier auskennen und Wohlfühlen
ihn dabei helfen können hier anzukommen
ich bin immer für pragmatische Lösung zu
haben und ich wäre glaube ich die letzte
die sagt der Standard muss in der Kita
noch eingehalten wenn da glaube ich
schon dass man auch darüber reden kann
wie man das schnell verbessern kann aber
das jetzt der Erzieherin Mangel so
hervorgehoben wird der war vorher
ehrlich gesagt auch schon da man hat
sich ja weil Lindemann das macht das
nicht besser aber es ist unredlich dass
in diese Verbindung zu bringen weil wir
müssen doch alles dafür tun die
Gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten und
deswegen sollten wir diese Zusammenhänge
nicht Menschen gegen Menschen aber jetzt
kommen genau in eine Situation in der
auch die Deutschen noch nicht waren wir
haben eine große Krise in Bezug auf
diesen Russland Krieg den Moskau gegen
die Ukraine führt wir haben eine
wachsende Inflation wir haben
Energiepreise die durch die Decke
schießen wir haben nicht nur eine
Rezessionsgefahr sondern wir sind
eigentlich kurz vor ihr es trifft also
eine Bevölkerung in Angst auf eine große
Zahl von Flüchtlingen und ich möchte
gern unbedingt jemanden mit in die Runde
holen und Ihnen kurz vorstellen circa
jendes nämlich die Geschäftsführerin der
Tafel in Deutschland Frau jendes sie
haben wenn man das diese
Situationsbeschreibung mal nimmt so eine
Art salzburgfunktion sie sehen sofort
wenn sich etwas verändert hier ist eine
Bevölkerung hoch alarmiert ob der
Situation in der sich Europa und
Deutschland gerade befindet viele Krisen
übereinander und auf diese Situation
kommen jetzt ganz viele geflüchtete was
bedeutet das
die Tafeln sind tatsächlich in
Seismograph der Gesellschaft und wir
haben eine sehr sehr angespannte
Situation zurzeit wir haben seit Anfang
des Jahres ein
Kundenzuwachs von über 50 Prozent über
zwei Millionen Menschen die wir
unterstützen und wir haben mehr als 30
Prozent der Tafeln die temporäraufnahmen
Stopps schon verkündet haben weil sie
einfach keine Menschen mehr unterstützen
können und für sorgen können weil ja
auch alleine zurückgegangen ist was sie
gespendet bekommen was sie von den
Supermärkten von Hotels bekommen und
eben eine immer größere Zahl von
Menschen die Konflikte die es mit
ukrainischen Flüchtlingen gibt wie
beispielsweise in Weimar können Sie das
noch mal erzählen wie kam es dazu was
bedeutet das
zu Weimar ist es glaube ich ganz wichtig
dass man einmal auf die Fakten schaut in
den Medien war es ja ein Einkaufszettel
der angeblich von Ukrainisch
geflüchteten so abgegeben wurde dem war
nicht so es war nachgefragt von einer
Tafel was sich denn Kundinnen Ukrainisch
geflüchtete wünschen würden und da
tauchten da taucht das war ein Teil des
Einkaufszettels auch nur zu sehen in dem
Foto und da tauchte Kaviar auf richtig
wir haben da 2015 gute Erfahrungen
gemacht auch Menschen zu fragen aber
damals auch was sie gerne essen und das
wurde so dargestellt genauso wie mit
anderen Faktoren als wäre das jetzt
sozusagen der größte Konflikt und als
wäre da eine Haltung vorhanden die wir
so nicht bestätigen können so eine
anführungshaltung dazu muss man
allerdings auch wissen dass in Russland
und auch in der Ukraine Kaviar
tatsächlich so eine Art Schwarzbrot ist
und hier unter durchaus zu den
Grundnahrungsmitteln gehört wie ist es
im Osten wo viele Menschen helfen Frau
jendes wo viele Menschen auch in der
Tafel helfen die selber nicht viel mehr
Geld im Monat zur Verfügung haben gibt
es da auch eine zusätzliche
Konfliktsituation tatsächlich ist es so
dass wir in Westdeutschland eine andere
ehrenamtskultur haben als in
Ostdeutschland wir haben also in
Westdeutschland viel mehr Menschen die
so die klassischen Renten da sein
erreicht haben und den Tafeln
unterstützen wollen und im Osten sind es
tatsächlich an Ostdeutschland viele
Menschen die selber unsere Kunden sind
die dann eben aber das auch gerne helfen
und dort unterstützen wollen
aus unserer Sicht gibt es es gibt
Konflikte das muss man ganz klar
benennen aber aus unserer Sicht sind die
vor allen Dingen auf zwei Faktoren
zurückzuführen zum einen gibt es einfach
zu viele Armutsbetroffene Menschen es
werden mehr es sind nicht nur Ukrainisch
geflüchtete aufgrund der Energiekosten
und der Lebensmittel steigenden
Lebensmittelpreise sind es auch Menschen
die sich nicht haben vorstellen können
zu den Tafeln zu gehen ja und die
Behörden das wissen wir vermehrt von
Tafeln haben auch sehr viel Ukrainisch
geflüchtete zu den Kartoffeln geschickt
geht zu den Tafeln und das suggeriert
natürlich als wären wir ein Teil des
sozialstaatlichen Systems das sind wir
nicht wir sind eine
zivilgesellschaftliche
ehrenamtsorganisation wir retten
Lebensmittel das ist unsere eine Seite
der Medaille und geben sie an
Armutsbetroffene Menschen weiter wir
haben nicht alles und wir können nur das
weitergeben was wir bekommen wir
unterstützen wir versorgen nicht dass es
Aufgabe des Staates und insofern sind
eben auch neue Kunden zu ihnen gekommen
genau wie sie sagen die vorgestern noch
gar nicht dachten dass sie zu ihren
Kunden zählen würden wie ist das und das
gilt es noch zu fragen wie ist das mit
den Flüchtlingen die aus der über die
sogenannte Balkanroute kommen waren und
sind Iraker Afghanen und Syrer mit dabei
gibt es Konflikte und
Verteilungskonflikte jetzt auch unter
den vielen vielen Menschen dann vor Ort
an den Tafel
wir müssen uns da glaube ich einmal die
Situation vergegenwärtigen was in so
einer tafelausgabe täglich passiert da
kommen Menschen die sich nicht von der
Politik gehört fühlen die wirklich um
ihre Existenz kämpfen müssen die sind
angespannt die sind unterdrückt die sind
unter Druck das gehört gilt aber für
alle Menschen die zu uns kommen und
natürlich kommt es dazu Konflikten und
trotzdem haben wir 60.000 Ehrenamtliche
die wollen uns unterstützen die wollen
diesen Menschen helfen und das tun sie
tagtäglich
Frau Jannis klasse dass sie heute bei
uns sind kommen Sie bitte mit in die
Runde und schon machen wir weiter Herr
lindmann wir haben
festgestellt dass die Herzen
offensichtlich sogar noch ein bisschen
weiter offen sind als in zwei 15 kann es
aber tatsächlich eine Situation geben wo
ja unsere Möglichkeiten Enden also wo
auch die Bereitschaft der Menschen nicht
adäquat umgesetzt werden kann in eben
eine echte Hilfe weil auch die deutsche
Bevölkerung echt
ärmer wird wenn die deutsche Bevölkerung
sieht dass wir
in Kontrollverlust in Deutschland haben
den wir zum Teil 2015 hatten wo wir
Personen ins Land gelassen haben das tut
mir leid es tut mir leid in ihrem Buch
für Differenziertheit und das ist 0
differenziert das Wort Kontrollverlust
und was weiß ich ständig bei der AFD
höre 15 wann Personen da wussten wir
nicht wer im Land war und wer nicht dem
Land war und das darf nie wieder
passieren die Menschen haben eine große
Akzeptanz für unser wir haben es
geschafft in vielen Bereichen in manchen
Bereichen haben wir es nicht geschafft
wir haben leider noch zu viele im
Bereich Integration haben wir es nicht
geschafft wir haben zu viele Menschen
die in Hartz4 leben die zu uns gekommen
sind die wir eigentlich für den
Arbeitsmarkt hätten integrieren müssen
im Bildungssystem haben wir in
Deutschland in Bildungssystem haben wir
in Deutschland brennpunktviertel wo es
leider zu viele junge Menschen gibt die
zu wenig unterstützt werden um im
Unterricht mitzukommen ich könnte
rechtfertigen dass sie von
Kontrollverlust reden wir hatten damals
2015 haben wir die europäische die
Schengen Außengrenze nicht so geschützt
dass wir kontrollieren konnten wer kommt
ins Land wer kommt nicht ins Land wer
hat eine Berechtigung ins Land zu kommen
beziehungsweise ein schenkraum und
später nach Deutschland heute haben wir
eine Situation wo die Menschen über die
Balkanroute kommen und Frau Feser sie
haben als Innenministerin selbst das
sind doch einfach mal einmal austreten
Frau Müller die Innenministerin Frau
Feser sie haben selbst an der
bayerisch-österreichischen Grenze die
Kontrollen verlängert das heißt dort
gibt es Lage gerechtfertigte Kontrollen
Grenzkontrollen durch die Bundespolizei
jetzt sehen wir beispielsweise in der
Schweiz wo in der Woche 1.000 Personen
durchgewunken werden nach Deutschland es
gibt aber keine Kontrollen in Tschechien
auch wenn das weiter zunimmt Frau Illner
dann fehlt die Akzeptanz in Deutschland
für dieses Thema wenn die Menschen aber
sehen das ist rechtfertigt die Menschen
brauchen Hilfe jetzt auch mit der
Ukraine dann gibt es eine hohe
Bereitschaft die Menschen zu integrieren
und mitzumachen aber es braucht eine
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und die sehen wir im
Moment zum Teil nicht gerade an der
Schweizer Grenze und eine
österreichischen Grenze so jetzt ganz
klare Frage warum die Grenze zu
Tschechen zu Tschechien wird ja aber
nicht kontrolliert die zu Österreich
kontrollieren wir da verlängern Sie
jetzt warum warum die eine ja die andere
nein das kann ich Ihnen erklären ich
habe mit beiden Kollegen sehr viele
Gespräche gehabt mit dem
österreichischen Kollegen dann auch mit
dem tschechischen Kollegen und wir
hatten eine Grenzkontrolle zu Österreich
und in dieser Lage die wir haben sie
verlängert weil ich es nicht für geboten
gehalten habe in dieser Situation zu
öffnen weil das natürlich etwas
suggeriert womit ich im Moment dort ein
Problem provozieren könnte so die
Tschechen und die Österreicher haben
sich nach unseren Gesprächen bereit
erklärt Grenzkontrollen zur Slowakei
zuvorzunehmen deswegen war es auch nicht
nötig an der deutschen Außengrenze wo
wir im Alltag so viele enge Verbindungen
haben Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
Arbeitsbeziehung der Menschen die
tagtäglich pendeln was eben auch nicht
gewünscht ist dort Grenzkontrollen
einzuführen und zu wirklichen Problemen
führen könnte das ist die Begründung auf
dem Tisch ich möchte trotzdem noch mal
fragen Frau Müller sie sind ganz viel in
Ostdeutschland unterwegs sie haben auf
diesen
Protestdemonstrationen mit Menschen
gesprochen und haben hoffentlich
verstehen wollen warum und wogegen sie
potenziell ist jemand gleich ein Rassist
oder ein Extremist wenn er befürchtet
dass Deutschland auch überfordert sein
könnte nein grundsätzlich nicht ich
verstehe auch wenn man jetzt in der
aktuellen Lage man sieht die Gaspreise
werden steigen und so weiter wenn man
Sorgen hat absolut es kann auch jeder
grundsätzlich demonstrieren gehen
überhaupt kein Problem mit aber wenn man
vor Ort ist und es ist angemeldet zur
Nordsee 2 öffnen oder Frieden jetzt oder
wie auch immer die alle so heißen oder
unser Land zuerst über der AFD dann
trifft man eben auf Menschen die
mindestens rechts offen sind wenn nicht
mehr weil es geht dann eben nicht darum
dass man sagt wo die Preise sind so hoch
bitte hört auf uns bitte ändert was an
der Politik sondern da wird auf der
Bühne gesagt die Regierung muss weg es
muss durch den Reichstag gefegt werden
es geht immer um Flüchtlinge und es geht
immer sozusagen gegen die Ukraine pro
Russland das heißt wenn man da ist und
sagt ich habe wirklich gerade nur Sorgen
und dahin kommt und meines Erachtens als
wenn man dann sieht was für Symbole da
sind was für Sprüche da gemacht werden
dass man eben dieses gesamte
demokratische System eigentlich ablehnt
man sagt so geht es nicht mehr die da
oben gegen uns da unten das ist einfach
Demokratie feindlich und wenn man
wirklich Sorgen hat aber dieses System
eigentlich mag und irgendwie eigentlich
ein richtiger Patriot das in meinem
Sinne dann muss man nach Hause gehen und
zu einer anderen Demo geben und es gibt
andere Demos die nicht so sind
unterteilen Sie und wir sind an dem
Punkt wo wir vielleicht noch mal danach
fragen warum Hendrik wüst der
Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen Herr Linnemann in
seiner Regierungserklärung gesagt hat
wir schaffen das und noch angefügt hat
und ich sage das auch ganz bewusst also
auch dem Ministerpräsidenten
Nordrhein-Westfalens müssen die
Bürgermeister ja dann jetzt die Stube
einrennen und sagen dann hilf uns mal
oder lass die mit mir gemeinsam uns
gemeinsam paar Lösungen einfallen wie
wir das schaffen ja gekämpft auch
gestern in der Sitzung mit Herrn Scholz
dass das Geld kommt dass die die
Kommunen sind ja diejenigen nicht wir
hier in Berlin wir sitzen hier im Berlin
und sind weit weg in den Kommunen werden
die Fragen gestellt wo sind die
Unterkünfte wie mache ich das in der
Kita wir haben das doch von Herrn Palma
gehört und die brauchen doch unsere
Unterstützung und deswegen hat der wüst
das das völlig richtig angebracht also
zum einen ist uns ja gestern etwas
gelungen gemeinsam der Bundesregierung
gemeinsam mit den regierungschefinnen
und Chefs der Bundesländer nämlich das
zur Verfügung zu stellen es gibt 1,5
Milliarden mehr für die kommunale Ebene
über die Länder um die
Unterbringungssituation auch zu
verbessern und die Kosten auszugleichen
und es muss doch jetzt darum gehen zu
sagen wie können wir denn die Menschen
wie Sie es gerade beschrieben haben
entlasten und die Gesellschaft
zusammenhalten nicht die eine Gruppe
gegen die andere auszuspielen deswegen
ist doch das wirklich historische
entschädigungspaket jetzt das
Entlastungspaket der Bundesregierung was
ja jetzt gemeinsam auch mit den Ländern
auf den Weg gebracht wird das
entscheidende in dieser Situation
nämlich Menschen zu stützen sozial
abzufedern zu sagen wir sind dafür da
dass die Energiepreise nicht durch die
Decke gehen indem wir
fünf Millionen im Vergleich zu den 100
Millionen Milliarden Entschuldigung im
Vergleich zu den 200 Milliarden dem
doppelwumms und anderen klingt jetzt
auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel in meinem
Ohr aber Freude hat sich gemeldet genau
insgesamt 4,25 Milliarden
eben auch auf das Gefühl dass ich
sozusagen dass ich eine Armutsbetroffene
Gruppe gegen eine andere ausgespielt
worden sind da gegen wären wir uns ganz
ausdrücklich und ehrlich gesagt die
Erhöhung des Bürgergeldes auf eine auf
53 Euro mehr das wir haben nicht und
dann diese Diskussion die aus unserer
Sicht am Thema vorbeigeht ob unser
Sanktionen und ab welchem und welche
vertrauenszeit davor wir haben diese
Menschen vor Ort und auch übrigens und
die deutsche Bevölkerung die haben keine
Rücklagen da geht es nicht darum ob sie
sich an 49 euro-ticket leisten können
sondern die sind an einer ganz anderen
Stelle und hier fordern wir die Politik
auf sprechen Sie mit uns wir haben über
60.000 Ehrenamtliche die tagtäglich denn
die Menschen unterstützen wir wundern
uns wirklich warum die Politik wir haben
auch sozusagen uns an Sie gewandt an die
verschiedenen Ministerien nicht mit uns
ins Gespräch geht unser riesenfundus
nutzt und hier zu gemeinsamen Lösungen
kommen denn im Moment ruhen Sie sich auf
dem Ehrenamt zum Teil aus das Ehrenamt
ist belastet die sind müssen Menschen
wegschicken obwohl sie unterstützen
wollen sie brauchen völlig andere
Kompetenzen dabei wollen sie eigentlich
Lebensmittel retten und Essen ausgeben
und die Jobcenter beweisen gleich an die
Tafeln weiter und machen sich damit
natürlich auch erstens weniger Mühe und
die suggerieren ein völlig falsches
sozialstaatlichen Teil wir müssen lernen
Palma noch ist glaube ich schon der
richtige Weg sie haben ja zurecht
geschildert dass Menschen mit diesen
hohen Kosten kommen und ich glaube das
ist einfach wichtig ist den Deckel zu
machen Gaspreise und Strompreise und
dass das auch in der Gesellschaft hilft
den Preis zurückgeht sondern es wird
trotzdem auf einem hohen Niveau sein
aber klar das ist ein ist auch für die
Tafeln die natürlich auch unter
wahnsinnig hohen Energiekosten
Stromkosten auch für sie eine Hilfe wir
sind noch mal bei ganzes allerdings für
uns nicht wir müssen Palma noch mal in
die Diskussion holen und zwar mit einem
Vorwurf den Friedrich Merz nach dem
sozial-tourismus machte
darüber müssen wir auch zwingend noch
reden wir kommen noch mal auf eine
andere Art und Weise Entschuldigung zum
Bürgergeld zurück
mit der zukünftig Bürgergeld genannten
Sozialleistungen lohnt es sich auch für
Zuwanderer häufig nicht mehr eine
einfache Tätigkeit aufzunehmen und genau
das zieht die Menschen aus vielen
Ländern erst richtig an es schafft einen
sogenannten pull-faktor
so da ist er noch mal der pull-faktor
und auch für Zuwanderer häufig nicht
mehr attraktiv eine einfache Tätigkeit
aufzunehmen sie haben Herr Palma genau
das vorhin erwähnt sie haben gesagt das
ist auch in Tübingen schwer ist oder
insgesamt schwer gelingt Menschen in
Arbeit zu bringen die ich hierher
geflüchtet sind bestätigen Sie auch da
in der Sache die Äußerung von Friedrich
Merz
also ich werde jetzt sehr Ungarn zum
dauergrund Zeugen von Friedrich Merz
aber die Sache die Sachlage kann man
hier empörrisch überprüfen mit den
Ergebnissen seit 2015 ich habe die
Tübinger Zahlen im Gemeinderat
vorgestellt kürzlich wir haben da 800
erwerbsfähige Personen also nicht Kinder
nicht alte Menschen von denen sind 400
mehr als sechs Jahre nachdem sie zu uns
gekommen sind nicht den Ausbildung nicht
in Arbeit nicht erwerbstätig und die
andere Hälfte ist wiederum nur zur
Hälfte tatsächlich
sozialversicherungspflichtig beschäftigt
ich finde diese Ergebnisse können nicht
zufriedenstellen das bedeutet dass diese
Menschen dauerhaft von
Transferleistungen leben müssen das ist
auch eine Frage der Teilhabe in unserer
Gesellschaft und es bedeutet dass wir es
eben nicht schaffen Frau Müller hat es
vorher erwähnt die unbesetzten
Arbeitsplätze durch Migration zu
besetzen und dafür brauchen wir ganz
offensichtlich andere Anreizsysteme ich
habe auch das mal versucht wir haben die
nicht besetzbaren stellen bei der
Raumreinigung in der Stadt
mal Flüchtlingen übertragen wollen
bedauerlicherweise war nach zwei Monaten
niemand mehr da die haben alle gesagt
das ist nicht das was ich machen möchte
und mit den Transferleistungen komme ich
auch gut klar da habe ich nachher nicht
wesentlich weniger Geld und ich kündige
wieder das ist glaube ich nicht gut für
unsere Gesellschaft und wir müssen da
auch von geflüchteten mehr verlangen
können ohne dass einem das dann
vorgeworfen wird
Herr Knaus Frau
also eine eine Sache verstehe ich nicht
ganz im nächsten Jahr gehen eine Million
Erwerbstätige in Deutschland in Rente
und es kommen ein paar hunderttausend
nach darüber ich habe eine
österreichische Zeitung vor kurzem
250.000 Mitarbeiter gesucht das große
Thema überall also die Aufgabe die Herr
Palma richtig beschreibt wie bringen wir
Leute in Arbeit die haben wir so oder so
jetzt ist es aber so bei den
Ukrainerinnen ich habe mit dem
Stellvertreter des Bürger also mit dem
engsten Mitarbeiter des Bürgermeister in
Warschau vor kurzem geredet 70 Prozent
der Ukrainerinnen in Warschau im
arbeitswegenalter arbeiten das sind
Leute viele von denen wenn sie es nur
können wenn sie die Sprache haben wenn
sie einen Kindergarten haben oder
flexibel organisiert irgendeinen Ort wo
ihre Kinder sind die wollen auch
arbeiten wir haben in Deutschland in
Österreich aber auch in anderen Ländern
den Bedarf wir haben gleichzeitig der
Ukraine Versprechen gemacht der
europäischen Integration was ist besser
für die europäische Integration meine
Kinder waren in vielen verschiedenen
Schulen im Ausland wenn diese Kinder
jetzt während sie ein Jahr ein halbes
Jahr oder auch zwei Jahre drei Jahre wir
wissen es ja nicht wann sie zurückgehen
können Deutsch lernen Freunde finden die
Integration der Ukraine in Europa findet
heute statt durch die Familien das muss
man alles organisieren da braucht man
die Ressourcen man kann nicht die
Verwaltung überfordern man kann nicht
die Kommunen überfordern das ist eine
jahrhundert Aufgabe es ist die größte
Fluchtbewegung in Europa seit den 40er
Jahren aber es ist auch eine Chance und
dieses dieses Denken gerade für die
Parteien die demokratischen Parteien im
Bundestag und ich sehe
Unionspolitiker in den in den Rathäusern
die sagen ja das gleiche die sagen ja
auch wir brauchen eigentlich Leute wir
wollen wir können das mit den Mitteln
die wir haben oft nicht selbst
organisieren aber es ist hier eine
Gelegenheit etwas zu tun andere schaffen
es in Europa Deutschland kann das auch
schaffen und da muss man sich eben
ansehen was man ändern muss Sekunde
vorher das noch und dann ist Frau Feser
dran entschuldigung ich kann da nur
zustimmen wir brauchen einfach auch wir
sagen ja mal wir brauchen auch nur
soziale zeitenwände die auch anderes
Menschenbild suggeriert als immer diese
Aussagen und dann wollen sie bleiben
weil sie kriegen so und so viel mehr ich
glaube kein Mensch der aus Krieg
flüchtet hat sich das so ausgesucht die
Menschen kommen hier wirklich mit
traumatischen
mit Trauben an und sind hier wirklich
nicht weil sie sozusagen jetzt die
Möglichkeit haben 150 Euro mehr oder
weniger zu bekommen und deshalb kann ich
nur sagen diese soziale zeitenwände
dieses Menschenbild auch einfach in
Deutschland auch unter der deutschen
Bevölkerung die armuts betroffen ist wir
kennen den Hashtag ich bin
armutsbetroffen einfach mal zu ändern
nicht dieses selbstverschuldete immer in
den Vordergrund zu rücken das so leicht
empfunden wird sondern die eine
Integrationsleistung zu vollziehen auch
eine Möglichkeit wirklich jetzt
sozusagen als Gesellschaft als
Zivilgesellschaft zusammenzustehen
allerdings muss die Politik die
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen und das
vermissen wir so nochmal Entschuldigung
Frau Feser hat die genickt die ganze
Zeit gibt es noch was darüber hinaus ja
weil du diesen guten Gedanken nein also
den Gedanken teile ich komplett und
deswegen habe ich ja gesagt die Antwort
auf ihre Fragen sind die Verbesserung
des Sozialsystems dazu gehört natürlich
auch das Bürgergeld die Abkehr von Hartz
IV dazu gehört eine Kindergrundsicherung
die helfen würde was wir im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben aber
ich wollte auf Herrn Palmers Punkt noch
mal zu sprechen kommen warum haben wir
es denn nicht geschafft die Menschen zu
integrieren auf dem Arbeitsmarkt weil es
ja offensichtlich auch nicht gewollt war
die Gesetzgebung stand dagegen wir haben
jahrelang Menschen die hier gut
integriert sind mit dukettendungen hier
gelassen kein gesicherten
Aufenthaltsstatus das war nicht wirklich
der Weg in Integration in Arbeitsmarkt
also da haben wir jetzt begonnen mit dem
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht genau diesen
Gedanken zu verändern das gut
integrierte Menschen die hier sind
Qualifikationen mitbringen dass sie auch
direkt arbeiten dürfen dass sie und ich
glaube das würde hier waren Stichtag ein
Jahr Probezeit also da gibt es ja eine
Kette auch von Bedingungen was aber
eigentlich aber entschuldigung wenn ich
das Nachfrage Frau Feser ist das dann
nicht eigentlich ein Ausweis dessen dass
wir eigentlich nie schaffen geduldete
abzuschieben ist das nicht eine
Kapitulationserklärung
bei der misslungenen Abschiebungen
geduldet werden ja nicht abgeschoben
also es geht ja um vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtige dass da wir die ein
oder anderen Probleme haben die meine
Vorgänger auch versucht haben zu lösen
dass wir die rückführen können aber es
geht nicht um die Menschen die hier gut
alle gründet sind es gibt auch
praktische Gründe warum die nicht
zurückgeführt werden aber eigentlich
schon Veränderungen jetzt vorgenommen
auch gesetzliche Art die im Bundestag
gerade beraten werden um das zu
verbessern das will ich auch nur noch
mal sagen aber ich glaube dass wir eine
völlige Veränderung brauchen auch
anzuerkennende Deutschland das wären
Einwanderungsland sind und das Aktiv
auch gestalten mit Gesetzgebung und das
Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz ist der erste
Punkt eines großen migrationspaketes wo
wir genau das machen wollen wir sind
wirklich was Anwerben von Menschen mit
Arbeitsfähigkeiten sind wirklich
schlecht also dieses Recht ist ein guter
Anfang aber das 300.000 Menschen sind es
Deutschland die das Treffen ist aber am
Ende bleiben nach ihren eigenen
Schätzungen von Innenministerium nur
80.000 80.000 übrig die überhaupt dieses
Recht dann bekommt und diese ganzen
Bedingungen wir sind noch mal bei der
Frage Einwanderungsgesetz machen wir
sind bei der Frage die Union sagt ich
fasse sie übel zusammen Linnemann dass
das kein Anreiz ist für Menschen die
keine Arbeit haben wenn wir Ihnen den
Zugang zu diesem Arbeitsmarkt
freundlicher gestalten druckloser
gestalten sondern diesen Druck sogar
herausnehmen dagegen wollen sie sogar
stimmen sie wollen gegen das Bürgergeld
rotieren weil sie es für einen
politischen Fehler halten da geht es
aber um etwas Grundsätzliches aber ich
finde es schon mit Verlaub ihr sitzt
eine bundesinnenministerin die sagt dass
die Menschen nicht arbeiten können weil
sie geduldet werden und nicht arbeiten
dürfen ist Nummer das Beispiel Syrer die
eine hohe Anerkennungsquote haben eine
sehr sehr hohe da wir 100.000 in
Deutschland zwei Drittel davon leben in
Hartz IV also ich finde wir müssen in
einem Land leben wo man die Dinge
aussprechen darf ohne gleich in die
rechte Ecke gestellt zu werden wir
müssen sachlich miteinander reden und
Frau bundesinnenministerin was sie
gerade gesagt haben das ist einfach
sachlich falsch wir müssen uns die Frage
stellen und da sind wir glaube ich
wieder zusammen was können wir tun damit
wir die Menschen besser integrieren
damit sie arbeiten gehen dass der erste
Punkt beim Thema Bürgergeld da werde ich
Gegenstimmen ja aus voller Überzeugung
wir haben heute morgen im Handelsblatt
vom Institut der Weltwirtschaft in Kiel
ganz seriös die einfach mal acht
verschiedene Konstellationen
ausgerechnet haben die kommen zu den
Schluss dass in sechs verschiedenen
Konstellationen es besser ist man nimmt
das Bürgergeld als wenn man arbeitet und
da reden wir nicht um zwei drei Euros da
gibt es eine Familie einmal mit drei
Kindern einer arbeitet vollzeit
Geringverdiener der hat wenn er arbeiten
geht
880 Euro weniger als wenn er das
Bürgergeld bekommt selbst wenn man gar
keine Kinder hat ein paar eine arbeitet
niedrig Lohnbereich aber Vollzeit die
haben immer noch 230 Euro weniger als
der Linie der in Deutschland arbeitet
ist Arbeit in Deutschland eigentlich gar
nichts mehr wert Frau inner ich sage
Ihnen ganz ehrlich eigentlich müsste man
ein Denkmal bauen für die Menschen die
in Deutschland arbeiten gehen und ich
verstehe jeden Geringverdiener nein
Stopp Stopp es geht um bessere Löhne es
geht um bessere Löwe
ich gehe voll mit ihnen in die in die
Debatte dafür bräuchten sie einen
Mindestlohn bei einer Familien mit drei
Kindern ich überschlage das mal und
komme auf 15 16 Euro den fordern selbst
die Linken in Deutschland nicht und ganz
ehrlich ich verstehe jeden der sagt das
kann ich nicht mehr machen ich werde
jeden Tag angesprochen Frau Feser an
ihnen waren die 12 Euro schon zu viel
also das finde ich nur sagen dieses
Bürgergeld das verschiebt etwas in
Deutschland es verschieben etwas in
Deutschland wir ach wissen Sie 80 Euro
mehr für eine Familie mit drei Kindern
die wollen sie das jemanden
rechtfertigen einen Geringverdiener der
in Deutschland jeden Morgen 6 Uhr
aufsteht auf den Wecker kloppt und
arbeiten geht wie wollen Sie denn das
rechtfertigen dass der 800 Euro weniger
hat natürlich könnten Sie jetzt sagen
der kann ja zum Amt gehen und aufstocken
aber was ist das denn für ein
Gesellschaftsbild 40 Stunden arbeiten
und dann gehe ich noch aufstocken um das
gleiche zu bekommen wie jemand der nicht
arbeitet da bin ich raus das ist nicht
meine Politik und hat mit sozialer
Marktwirtschaft gar nichts aber auch
rein gar nichts mehr zu tun
dargestellt sie haben eben selbst darauf
hingewiesen dass man aufstocken kann und
dass das nicht automatisch so ist wenn
man Bürgergeld bekommt dass es sich
nicht mehr lohnt in Deutschland zu
arbeiten das stimmt einfach nicht aber
auch eingearbeitet gar nicht und sie
haben die Bericht von der Tafel gehört
über welche Themen wir reden über Armut
die sich ja in den Tafeln tagtäglich
zeigt was ja zeigt dass wir
Sozialstiftung meine ganzen Honorare wir
müssen was für dieses Thema tun aber
vergessen Sie doch bitte nicht die
Millionen Menschen die jeden Morgen
aufstehen und arbeiten gehen die müssen
doch was in Portemonnaie haben und nicht
diejenigen die nicht arbeiten
die müssen wir unterstützen auch was
Bundessozialgericht sagt bzw das
Bundesverfassungsgericht die müssen auch
jetzt ein Inflationsausgleich bekommen
ist doch klar aber ansonsten müssen wir
doch die Menschen ermuntern arbeiten zu
gehen und sie haben doch auch eine
Bringschuld zu sagen ja wir machen das
jetzt und das was Gerhard Schröder dass
ich hier in der Sendung sitze und noch
Gerhard Schröder verteidigen muss da
rede ich jetzt nicht von Russland der
hat fördern und fördern eingeführt sie
streichen jetzt das Thema fordern und es
gibt nur noch ein fördern und da sind
wir einfach rausholen danke dass ich das
noch sagen durfte es ist nicht komme ich
auch wieder runter gerade klarstellen
das ist nicht richtig weil gerade das
Bürgergeld Anreize dafür setzt und zwar
sehr hohe dass man sich weiter
qualifiziert und weiterbildet es gibt
bis zu 130 Euro
bis zu 130 Euro mehr im Monat wenn man
eine Wahltag Qualifizierung macht und
das sind die Anreize die man setzen muss
damit die Menschen in Arbeit kommen eine
Perspektive bekommen und deswegen ist
das Bürgergeld auch richtig und bitte
verkürzen Sie es nicht so sehr wir
bei der das ist ja ein interessanter
Punkt auf Gerhard Schröder noch mal zu
verweisen
letzte Frage Herr Palma vielleicht in
ihre Richtung wir sind mit der Agenda
2010 gestartet und dieser Regierung
damals ja gestartet in einer riesigen
Arbeitslosigkeit um Menschen wieder in
Arbeit zu bringen und jetzt brauchen wir
Fachkräfte und suchen dringend Menschen
die zusätzlich nach Deutschland kommen
und suchen an allen Ecken und Enden
Menschen die arbeiten und erleichtern
wie formuliere ich das jetzt erleichtern
indem den Druck raus also ist das auch
in ihren Ohren unlogisch schließen sie
sich eher Herrn Lindemann an oder Frau
Fehse
die Frage war wieder lang ich hoffe ich
habe Sie richtig verstanden ich glaube
das Problem der fehlenden Anreize
materiellen Anreize zu arbeiten besteht
in den Gesellschaftsgruppen in denen
Arbeiten nicht per se schon mal aufgrund
des Status notwendig ist und da geht es
auch nicht so sehr um das
hochqualifizierte da schaut die
Weiterqualifizierung nicht wesentlich
sondern wir haben auch ganz viele
ungelernte Tätigkeiten wo sich niemand
mehr findet und die Frage zu stellen wie
man das richtig konstruiert dass da ein
Anreiz zur Arbeitsaufnahme besteht das
halte ich für nötig da bin ich bei Herrn
Linnemann und ganz objektiv ist es zu
wenig denn es kann nicht erklärt werden
dass so viele Stellen in diesem Bereich
unbesetzt sind wären auf der anderen
Seite hunderttausende keine Arbeit
aufnehmen dieses Thema ernsthaft
anzugehen hielt ich schon für nötig was
aber nicht gegen das Bürgergeld spricht
sondern eher die Frage der Transfer
entzugsrats transferentzugsrate und der
Frage der Sanktionen betrifft
und dann sind wir Herr Knaus noch mal
bei dem Blick nach vorn und sagen das
ist zu schaffen sie sind optimistisch
dass diese
riesenkrise zu bewältigen ist hier in
Europa und in Deutschland oder sind wir
tatsächlich davor nicht gefeit eben auch
in eine gefährliche Situation hinein
also
wir sind hier jetzt mittlerweile längst
eine Nachricht in einer
Schicksalsgemeinschaft mit den Ukrainern